[Music]
our next story takes us to Broward
County Florida where a family sued
McDonald's because they say that one of
the restaurants chicken nuggets caused a
serious burn to their child's thigh a
jury came back Thursday with a split
decision in court this week attorneys
for Falana homes and Umberto Estevez
said a 200 degree McNugget fell out of
the Happy Meal carrier and onto their
four-year-old's lap in the car they say
the Nugget got stuck between the child's
leg and the seat belt and there was in
there until Holmes could pull over and
figure out what was going on the family
sued McDonald's as well as the franchise
owner for negligence the jury determined
the companies failed to put warnings on
the food which led to the girl's injury
but McDonald's was found not negligent
for causing the burns the family is
seeking fifteen thousand dollars and
attorneys say another trial will
determine how much McDonald's in the
franchise owner will have to pay in
Damages now this lawsuit likely reminds
you of the McDonald's Hot Coffee case
from the 1990s right because that became
the poster child for so-called frivolous
lawsuits but it turns out a lot of white
you might remember from that case isn't
necessarily true so we want to debunk
some of the top misconceptions of that
case let's talk about it so first up
many people remember the victim in this
case as 79 year old Stella lieback
spilling hot coffee on her lap as she
tried to take the lid off and drive at
the same time in reality she was the
passenger in a car without cup holders
her nephew Christopher was actually
driving after they went through the
drive-through line Christopher pulled
over into a parking spot lybeck put the
cup of coffee between her legs pulling
the lid toward her so that she could put
in cream and sugar and the entire thing
spelled it spelled into her lap it's
believed the coffee was between 190 and
210 degrees the sweatpants that she was
wearing were seared to her skin causing
her injuries to be even worse in fact
her Physicians said that they were some
of the worst Burns he had ever treated
there's another misconception and that
was that lie back was just out for as
much money as she could get but
according to her family she had asked
McDonald's for a low amount to cover her
medical costs when she originally
reached out to the corporation
requesting that they cover her bills
McDonald's responded with an offer of
eight hundred dollars that's when she
sued asking for 125 000 it was the jury
in the case that decided to award her a
hundred sixty thousand dollars in
compensatory damages and 2.7 million
dollars in punitive damages but lybeck
never saw that much money the amount was
reduced multiple times and the final
amount was settled out of court it's
believed to have been around five
hundred thousand dollars liveex family
says that she used the money to pay for
a Living Nurse there's a third element
of the trial that a lot of people
latched on to it is the duh factor of
course coffee's hot right if someone
spills it on themselves it's not the
fault of the restaurant that sold it but
during the trial it was revealed that
McDonald's knew of at least 700
instances of its coffee causing serious
Burns to people's bodies even skull
holding children the temperature of
coffee someone got at McDonald's was Far
hotter than coffee brewed in a machine
at home experts testified that serving
coffee at a slightly cooler temperature
would decrease the risk of third degree
burns even McDonald's quality control
manager conceded that drinking the
restaurant's coffee right after it was
served could cause Burns to a person's
mouth and throat alright let's get into
this so Terry the plaintiffs won the
failure to warn claim but what exactly
is that and what type of Damages could
they recover well failure to warn is a
type of liability case and it's exactly
what it sounds like when the
manufacturer of that product doesn't
tell the customer what they should do to
take precautions so you usually see it
in cases for electronics but here the
product is the coffee and that here the
product is that actual chicken McNuggets
so they should have worn in the prior
case and in this case now if in fact
they lose this case the plaintiff could
be entitled to economic and non-economic
damages so anything from medical costs
and anything from lost wages that would
include the economic damages and the
non-economic damages would include like
pain and suffering and it would count
for the pain and suffering of the family
including that child who apparently is
very aware of that Scar from that nugget
let's go back to law school Brian so the
parents lawsuit is suing for strict
liability and negligence why both what's
the difference between the two yeah just
you go for both because you want to see
whatever Theory could work for you when
it comes to strict liability negligence
you might have also heard terms like
recklessness knowingly these are levels
of mental state or men's rape who really
want to go back to law school strict
liability it means it doesn't matter
what you were thinking if you did
something wrong then you are liable for
it and that's often times for either the
most absurd things you do wrong like
having a coffee at a million degrees
Kelvin or blasting or or certain type of
dangerous activities but negligence is
when you do not take reasonable care
there are different levels of
understanding but doesn't seem like one
on that but as Terry described they did
have one claim that they won okay